If you heard of this product, or if you talk to my radiation,
diacid, vitamin A, vitamin D, vitamin C,
vitamin E, B complex, and B1.
No, I haven't.
Diacid will help open up your vessels.
That's what the whole purpose of taking extra diacid would do.
It can dilate your vessels.
Vitamin A is needed for your heart and so many things, D,
that's a fairly small amount of D.
Vitamin C at two grams.
That means you'd probably be absorbing from on half of that.
That would be an antioxidant.
If you have cancer, I wouldn't suggest taking that level of vitamin C.
The B complex is something I probably wouldn't recommend to most people with cancer
because it probably has methyl groups.
But otherwise, I don't know how that is helping with radiation to talk
with the patient over the ghost limbs.